son las lluvias más fuertes en mil años
según expertos la provincia de henán en
el centro de china es la más afectada
por las inundaciones la ciudad de
zhengzhou se ha llevado la peor parte la
inundación del metro de esta urbe de
unos 12 millones de personas provocó
varias muertes dejó unos 600 heridos y
obligó a las autoridades a proceder con
intensas labores de rescate hemos
evacuado con éxito a más de 500 personas
y reparado presas y embalses en dos
lugares después de un día de rescate
según datos meteorológicos habrán
lluvias continuas en los próximos días
estamos totalmente preparados para
diversas tareas inesperadas asegurando
la seguridad de la vida y las
propiedades de las personas la provincia
de henán ha situado su nivel de
emergencia en dos siendo el 1 el máximo
en una escala de 4 entre el sábado y el
martes cayeron más de 600 milímetros de
lluvia algo equivalente a casi un año de
precipitaciones varios edificios se han
perdido acceso al agua y a la
electricidad las calles han sido
cerradas y los viajes aéreos y
terrestres pospuesto
además 100.000 personas han sido
evacuadas la inundación fue demasiado
poderosa y la gente fue arrastrada entre
las varias personas restantes otra
persona y yo casi nos rendimos porque ya
no teníamos fuerzas suficientes pero mi
brazo seguía agarrando una barandilla al
lado mío el presidente chino xi jinping
ha calificado la situación como
extremadamente grave en la región de
henán que cuenta con más de 100 millones
de habitantes también peligran decenas
de represas cuyos niveles generan alerta